Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie a lot of you have
been asking me about where Spider-Man homecoming
fits in the marvel time so this is going to
be a complete breakdown of all the marvel
phase 3 movies and where they fit in the continuity.
There is a new round of the Spider-Man giveaway
that starts now.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything during the break.
So the cool thing they did is they cut the
Spider-Man teaser and the homecoming trailer
and the international trailer in a way that
allowed you to contextualize it with the end
of Civil War like this is when he gets the
suit.
This is when he's in Civil War doing all the
stuff this is him getting dropped back off
in his neighborhood getting ready to start
his sophomore year of high school, so Spider-Man
homecoming will make it really easy to judge
the marvel timeline usually you can kind of
guess when the movie is taking place in the
movies themselves move in real time.
So Ant-Man happens right after the events
of age of old but the kind of changing that
a little bit because there's going to be three
movies a year really soon.
So it gets a little confusing and then you
have movies like Doctor strange they have
to do origin story stuff, so they flashbacks
they jump around in time little bit.
So here's an explanation for the timeline
where.
Spider-Man homecoming fits into the events
of all the phase 3 movies.
The only wildcards on this are Black Panther,
and Captain Marvel because those are so far
off those will probably do the same thing
the Doctor strange did where they flash back
then they pick up in present-day, but the
very first Marvel phase 3 movie is Captain
America Civil War.
The problem is is that it's not the beginning
of the phase 3 timeline because technically
that's Doctor strange.
So the end of Doctor strange in the end of
Captain America Civil War sink up in the timeline
at the beginning of Doctor strange when he
still just a doctor before he has his accident
is after winter soldier and potentially after
age of Ultron because the avengers tower exists,
but before Captain America Civil War, so a
lot of you are asking what was the deal with
that winter soldier shoutout Kevin fight he
clarified that the only reason that Hydra
considered him a threat and had him on their
list was because of his extreme aptitude as
a doctor.
They didn't know anything about him becoming
a future sorcerer supreme.
So he was a threat, just because he was super
smart and then you know, just because it's
hard to guess where it falls relative to age
of all even after they built the new Avengers
facility the avengers tower still exists in
New York City they do so use it as a base
of operations anymore, so when we see.
Spider-Man homecoming if he goes to Manhattan
will probably see the avengers tower and the
skyline then you have the first part of Captain
America Civil War were Tony goes to Queens
recruit Spider-Man and then sends him to this
hotel where he gets the new suit is a battalion
where she wishes force in case KCC the case
of his suppose it is that he fights in the
airport battle scene and Tony takes him back
to his neighborhood says he can keep the suit
and you have like the duration of this trailer
here all the events of the Spider-Man homecoming
movie tickets to keep the suit course done
for me.
Just don't do anything I would do and deafly
do to anything I wouldn't little gray area
in there and that's where you operate.
But this does not mean you're an avenger cancer
on the son of indiscriminate good luck after
in that movie basically goes from the fall
of this year to the spring of next year's
he's a sophomore in high school, so the film
itself will take place over like a six month
period or so but they do flash back in time
to when he's wearing the old school hoodies
suit before he gets that Stark tech suit.
So they will jump around in time just like
they did in Doctor strange, but then around
the same time you have Thor meeting with Doctor
strange, to try and find Odin.
So that supposedly takes place within about
six months of the end of Doctor strange is
wearing the gloves he's been the caretaker
of the New York sanctum for at least a couple
months.
So will happen is is will you pick up at the
beginning of Thor Ragnarok that movie will
take place like right after this moment happening
here at the end of the Doctor strange movie
which is also somewhere right around the beginning
of Spider-Man homecoming.
So you have all these different movies that
all converge at different points within the
end of Ragnarok and Black Panther both lead
into the first infinity war film you also
have guardians of the galaxy doing the same
thing to go until we get a little more information
we have to assume that Thor Ragnarok and guardians
of the galaxy and Black Panther are all occurring
at the exact same time, those movies will
end around the same time and then very shortly
after that the events of infinity war pick
up and even though there's always a bunch
of Post credits teasers that set up stuff
like the big Avengers films with the probably
do is apply use Thor Ragnarok to tease infinity
war the most is because there's so much Santos
infinity gem stuff going on and that in the
thing about guardians of the Galaxy to is
that there's no Sandoz and no infinity stones
James Gunn already confirm.
So we arrived at the first big benchmark infinity
war part one what happens after that.
So that you these have like part one part
two, so they just said that they're going
to name the second Avengers film something
completely different.
Because they are two completely different
films, so the first big film after infinity
war is gonna be ant Man in the WASP that's
can it be where the new WASP costume is supposed
to debut Evangeline Lilly said that they opted
to just hold off on it so that they wouldn't
be taking something away like a big reveal
a way from their own franchise like ant Man
the wasp great characters is can be a lot
of fun but just like Doctor strange was a
slightly weirder smaller movie than Seneca
big Avengers team up man in the WASP will
have a lot of the same energy that you saw
in the first film like a great sense of humor
a really weird story that can be self-contained.
But also connected to the other films.
But here's the thing though infinity war is
going to fundamentally change the marvel universe
all the characters, the relationships to say
nothing of with the multi-verse looks like
like they Enos tries to destroy it with the
snap of his fingers like he did in the comics
and who knows what can happen even if they're
able to fix it things will just go back to
normal so also picking up in the wake of infinity
war is the Captain Marvel movie.
So it sounds like what can happen is is that
even though Captain Marvel is being released
after ant Man the wasp both of those movies
will be happening concurrently picking up
right after infinity war because Captain Marvel's
sort of getting the Spider-Man treatment in
infinity war where she has like a brief appearance,
but it's really huge she probably gets her
powers via a soul gem and then they sort of
deal with the ramifications of that in the
Captain Marvel movie, just like they're dealing
with.
Spider-Man and Spider-Man homecoming.
Even though we've already seen him in the
Stark tech suit, and Captain America Civil
War so Captain Marvel gets her fully fledged
story we learn all about her.
Then after that movie.
The next one is the second untitled avengers
film no that'll probably be is something like
all new all different avengers were, they
just shuffle the roster bring some people
in bring some people out.
So that's really sort of the end of phase
3 they might tack on some extra films at the
end of that depending on the performance of
some of the phase 3 movies they're all doing
really well.
So far, they just tease that phase 4 is gonna
look radically different, so the timeline
those movies is totally up in the air, but
what you will see like the kind of teased.
This is is a lot more crossovers like Thor
Ragnarok is sort of a planet hold movie if
like a buddy road trip movie you will see
more team ups style movies like that instead
of seeing like Iron Man for you Mike to see
Iron Man team up with another character like
Doctor strange.
So just allows them to have some fun with
the characters in a way that they might not
have been able to do with the standalone films
and phase 1 phase 2.
Forget the flying monster the people who matter
what the promise if you need us need me.
So let me know if you guys have any more questions
about the Marvel phase 3 timeline when all
these films are taking place when they begin
where Spider-Man fits into all of this, but
for the most part.
Up to now they've all moved in real time.
The exception to that is when they flashback
for brief scenes like when the doing origin
stories or when they're doing something totally
different like guardians of the Galaxy like
James Gunn has even gone as far to Joe that
they're in a different universe like the guardians
are totally removed from everything that's
going on the main Marvel films.
I haven't had to worry about continuity or
anything like that.
So really the connective tissue at that point
is the post credits scenes like that's what
they used to sort of link everything up.
Don't worry when you go see guardians of the
galaxy next spring they will pry be a Thor
Post credit scene that will explain how the
guardians are related to the marvel universe
just because the both space-based franchises
and you get a little teaser for infinity war
and then during the Earth-based avengers films
you get, Post credit teasers for everything
that will eventually link up to infinity war
so they tend to group the Earth-based avengers
movies together when it comes to teasing other
movies they've thus far kept the space-based
movies sort of self-contained themselves to
like the end of Thor the dark world teased
the first guardians of the Galaxy movie.
So the pry just continue to do the same thing,
so was can happen next is I'm in a post of
Star Wars OB one video I'll do a new video
about arrow in the return of a really big
character then they'll be Star Wars Rogue
one Easter eggs, so be sure and go see the
movie if you haven't seen it yet aborted posted
my non-spoil review, so be sure to link that
at the end of this what you guys wait for
that to post you can click here for my non-spoil
re-Rogue one review and you can click here
to rewatch the Spider-Man trailer's thank
you so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight!